[Applause]
thanks very much emilyn so as he had
said so i'm susan mulcahy and i'm here
for the final uh talk today which i
thought either is going to work
well for me or it's going to be kind of
the worst decision ever to kind of be
here at the end of three days but i have
made it here so um so yeah so i'm i'm
susan mulcahy and yes i'm going to be
congratulating you on making it to the
end of the conference in addition to
some light-hearted thoughts on
conversing about data
um and first i think because i'm up here
speaking in front of you it makes a
little bit of sense just to tell you a
bit about who i am um in addition to the
fact that you've probably heard my
accent in the three known nanoseconds
that i've been speaking already you
probably guessed that i'm american and
you are correct so tick uh number one
that you you've got that on there
um so i'll give you some of the
background about uh kind of what brings
me here but first because you hear the
accent i think it's maybe good just to
go around some of the places in the
world uh that got me here
so uh yes i was born in new york state
and grew up in connecticut right next
door um high school there and everything
then i went to purdue university where i
did mechanical engineering this is a
while ago now
i had a dream to design artificial limbs
for athletes at the time
and and then
got into mechanical engineering and
started working for hp
but during the time that i did my
undergraduate
then i did a semester in denmark and
that's where then i did kind of all the
elective courses
and then when i came back though i was
out of sync for all the engineering
courses so i had to still take another
uh term to kind of get through those
um but made it through those and i still
remember coming back so i'd i'd um
in addition to doing mechanical
engineering then i also rode on the crew
team
and i still remember being in the gym
once and uh you know with the crew team
and we were doing our workouts and there
was some guy that walked up to me and
just said you're that girl in my
thermodynamics class and i thought um
yeah i guess i am but you know me i
don't know you but so that's a little
bit of the life of being a perhaps a
female in this industry um but we are
making strides and we are changing that
over time so
oh great so um went to denmark and then
came back finished the degree started
working for hp in oregon san diego um
and then moved to france with hp and was
there for a few years
um went up to uh fontenblo in france
which i'll talk about a little bit um
came back to well went up to london back
to the states over to tokyo
for a couple years so i was there for
two years and then from tokyo 13 years
ago moved here to london so i'm here now
kids in school this is home i'm settled
and love it
so that's what brings me here so london
but in the process of doing all of that
and with hp and the jobs that i had when
i came back to london i thought you know
what i'd really be interested in getting
back into
some of that bioengineering side of
things that interested me
so i ended up at imperial college and i
did a master's and a phd and in the
process of learning about bioengineering
and at the time it was traumatic brain
injury i discovered data
and that's really what then gets me here
because i found that of course across
any of the fields or domains and sectors
that you might be in
data coding um at the time i was using
matlab which i loved and then moved on
into python or maybe there's another
matlab fan out there but um i really
like okay good i kind of feel it's a
type of thing where you feel like
sometimes you say to matlab and you know
you kind of get maybe a nod or nothing
at all or um and then i can even go back
and say that in my undergraduate like
technically i was just starting but i
actually did fortran at the very
beginning and before i switched to all
of these over to all these others but
yeah i loved matlab um but so now i'm in
python so um that's that's where my
world is now but so i digress
so i got into the data science side of
things and did the phd and found i loved
data but you might find maybe through
this talk i can be quite conversational
in the way that i
um
talk about technical topics and i found
for me
that has
bode well for either presenting or
talking about technical topics maybe
more than doing the research and that's
actually pulled me into my field um
where i'm running a program at imperial
now called data spark
and this is where we match up our
industry partners
with five of our postgraduate students
for a six-week data analytics sprint and
we've had projects that are the students
are doing this project that it's meant
to be student-led
and they're doing projects um in
everything from
um with big energy companies on kind of
gas
distribution um others on price
optimization um looking for
profitability in certain
departments of of law firms
or looking at we did just finished one
with chatham house the uk think tank
and looking at nuclear proliferation
and the the relationships between um
countries and the alliances that are out
there so as we all know data science
really spans all of the different
sectors and industries that are out
there so i have found something that's
really important is being able to bridge
doing the technical side and talking
about it to non-specialists and that's
really going to bring me into my talk
for today
um
so i'm hoping that i haven't really
forgotten anything on some of those
slides there but
so
what is it that you've just been through
you've been through three days full of
talks we have just a sample of the talks
that are here but more than 50 sessions
over the last three days
and i would just like to actually
congratulate you for making it this far
and maybe if i can almost congratulate
me in the sense that i feel like the
fact that there are more than two of you
in this room i already consider this a
smashing success
so i'm quite pleased with that actually
because i wasn't quite sure what i would
walk into here but you've made it
through those uh talks and you've you've
actually made it now to the four o'clock
talk on sunday so thanks for being here
as well with that
but so lots of information that's here
and with that your brains are full right
now you've learned new things maybe you
were speakers presenting new things
fitting it into your research or the
work that you do
and it's all technical right and some of
them are going to be more technical than
others uh you know looking even through
some of the titles that we didn't manage
to sit in on those talks
some are quite funny and some are quite
serious there's going to be a range of
them but of course we know that getting
out into business we have to be able to
communicate our results to others that
might not be specialists
and that brings me into um
yes
the messages that i'm going to bring but
i did put up this slide here the tldr in
that
i'm wondering if you are here now just
because it's like it's four o'clock it's
the closing keynote or actually you read
my abstract and you thought yes i want
to come maybe it was too long maybe you
didn't read it because in all honesty i
only submitted it two days ago so in all
likelihood you didn't read it and you're
just here thinking i'll show up to that
and let's see what she has to say
so that then brings us into um this this
message of
these ideas of what you've just been
hearing over the last three days and how
we can then bring that into
dare i say everybody else that's out
there that's not in this conference that
maybe we work with whether they're
managers or executives or there are
people that
the point that i often want to make is
that there are other really smart people
out there that might not be
knowledgeable in this specific area so
they're very technical but they might
not be specialists in this area so we're
often having to find ways to
communicate
with others outside our domains so
talking about why is it important and
also then how can we bridge the gap
across these specialties
and just because i am the way i am i'm
going to have some light-hearted
examples in there as well
so i'll even start off with one
to say maybe set the stage a little bit
on
even getting more people into the
conversation on data
and the fact that we all have different
perspectives often on
even when we're looking at the same
thing that's going to be kind of a theme
of what we're what we're talking about
here so with this in mind so i had to um
host an awards dinner uh last week
and um it was not in this room but i
thought that was a nice picture and i
get to choose the pictures that i put up
so it was in a really nice room but it
was not this one specifically it was an
imperial college it was for this data
spark program that i mentioned so we had
our
industry partners there we had students
that were there we were celebrating
their success we had the vice dean of
education with my boss that was there
you know i was trying to make a good
impression
um and i kind of but we also had you
know probably 25 people in the room and
then we were also trying to dial in at
least 20 or so people virtually so we
were doing the virtual event and trying
to make sure that everybody felt
included
so i kind of said to my kids ahead of
time you know do you have any
suggestions for how i can kind of you
know warm up the crowd a little bit and
um you know we're gonna have some people
virtually and yet some people in london
and but the virtual ones they were
dialing in from asia from brazil from
the states and
um oh my kids say yeah mom i've got a
great idea you know you should do a pub
quiz on love island
and i
i kind of you know
thought about it not for long and i just
thought that's not quite the vibe i'm
going for
so i did not do that you will maybe be
happy to hear may be disappointed to
hear that i did not do that but i did
not go with that one
but i did though decide to do some type
of uh kind of pub quiz of bringing
people into the london frame of mind
so um i ended up doing a short quiz on
emojis of london tube stations okay kind
of thought there are enough people
around that should be able to figure
this out a bit so
right so of the ones that we we had so i
kind of had 10 different ones i'm not
going to go through all 10.
but of the 10 tube stations um here was
one of the questions so first one up um
or this wasn't the first one but here's
the one i'm going to show you which tube
station is this one
question for you
elephant and castle
oxford circus i heard piccadilly circus
a few things out there yeah so it's like
you look at it and you kind of think i
can probably figure that out and then
you look and yeah
trying to kind of figure out what we're
actually looking at so then i actually
wanted to use technology of course
because we had these people dialing in
from you know around the world so i had
one of these meant to meter like word
clouds so people could submit their
answers
and i'm gonna you know i'm gonna share
that with you here so yeah so we did get
a bunch of answers you will be pleased
to see that elephant in castle is on
there yes
oxford circus is the correct answer in
this um there was a piccadilly circus
there's also bull ring on here the one
that i think is quite you know clever
even they were just straightforward cow
tent
cow tent right so they just went
straight in and they thought i'm
bringing it back to basics here folks
so they said cow tent you know it's true
that's what we're looking at cow tent
um but so again we're all looking at
those two emojis and we all have
different answers for what we are
looking at so it's just remembering that
we will have different perspectives on
that
so just to kind of just for the fun of
it i'm going to go with one more here as
well
so one more that came up
what's your thought
waterloo great so that's it um now maybe
in here with a very londony crowd this
is quite obvious having that come up
again keep in mind there were people
dialing in
that were not all from london
so it wasn't so obvious for everybody
else that was dialing in
so the answers that we got there yeah we
got we got a number of them
we got a number of answers and you know
some of them you kind of think yeah okay
we'll go with that so okay we're going
to start easy we're here right so of
course yes the correct answer is
waterloo
but then you know going for the
straightforward shower toilet
good i like that i like that but uh
black friar that's an interesting
interpretation but the one that really
got me
shore ditch
let's think about that one for a moment
okay
sure
ditch right okay so yeah they were going
creative on that one and maybe they
didn't really know but they they thought
that could be waterloo so
um maybe someone that just likes toilet
humor um but anyway so that that was
that was that was what was happening
there but of course this is all coming
coming up i'm supposed to bring us back
to data and conversations what's the
point of all of this
well part of it's just remembering that
we can all look at the same thing
and we can then have different
perspectives so different people can
look at the same thing and have
different perspectives on it so we can
see that
but so let's remember that everything we
end up seeing
is really a perspective
and i know that in this world especially
in a very technical room we like to
believe that it's all about ones and
zeros i mean i gotta tell you when i am
teaching a class on python or pandas and
i get to the point on boolean values i
feel like i just find such satisfaction
in some of it something in life that's
either true or it's false right it's one
or the other it's true or it's false
there's something so satisfying about it
i know not everyone gets that excited
about it but i find it quite satisfying
but in reality everything we see is
really perspective it's not necessarily
the ground truth but it's what we're
seeing
and sometimes what we actually see
depends mainly on what we look for
so we have to remember that as well that
again we're not always seeing what
everyone else might be seeing
and that our perceptions are fallible
we sometimes see what isn't there and we
are prey to optical illusions
occasionally we hallucinate we are error
prone
so it's hard to think about that because
we kind of think no we are technical
people and we kind of can put things
into nice categories and boxes but it
doesn't always work that way
but of course sometimes our eyes deceive
us
this here
these are actually
two
perfectly smooth circles
but they don't look like it
but we keep saying no they must be well
no they're not
but actually if you took say a ruler or
checked the diameter all the way around
these are perfectly smooth circles
yeah i know it's it's kind of you kind
of think it can't be but it deceives us
and so even when we're sitting here
knowing that it is we don't believe it
so again we have different perspectives
on this so a lot of this is just
thinking about okay there are other
perspectives out there and sometimes we
can fool ourselves
so let's think about some of the
examples we've seen in the past right
some of those so how about this one
we remember that one the old blue and
black dress or that's what i think it
was
what about everybody else who saw
i'm on this team i'm blue and black
blue and black
okay okay good number of you
how about people that saw i think some
people say that this is white and gold
see i
am i really
the first time the first time when this
first came up and someone said white and
gold i thought it was like candid camera
i thought how is it possible that
someone's actually seeing that as white
and gold and even now when i look at
this i still feel like
maybe that's light blue and a bit of
bronze in there but it's not white and
gold but i get it i've kind of heard
it's about has to do with natural light
versus inter inside light and everyone
sees different things but anyway our
eyes it can kind of fool us
um how about this one
what do you see
duck
rabbit
duck
rabbit
once you see so you usually see one to
start with and then it takes a moment
and then you'll see the other one but
again we don't always see it and then we
realize
once someone says oh like i probably see
duck first but then when someone says
rabbit i think oh actually
there's another perspective and now that
you've said it i can see it but i
couldn't see it at first
so it's just reminding us actually maybe
there are a couple perspectives and that
we we do see it in there okay here's one
that kind of can trick us a little bit
is this woman spinning clockwise or
counterclockwise
i'm hearing both i'm hearing
counterclockwise
i'm hearing clockwise right
so but actually the way the way she's
spinning and the way we're just seeing
the silhouette
actually
which of us is right is she going
clockwise or counterclockwise
are you right or am i right because i
kind of think maybe she's spinning one
way but maybe she's spinning the other
way
are we both right and sorry i had to
throw this in here is this feeling a
little quantum
but
basically it's just this thought of
actually right let's go back now
we can see it and actually maybe we
can't quite tell from here
but if we add one little line
there's now
this one on the left there's a little
white line that's drawn in
to kind of imply that she's spinning to
the left and this one here there's a
little white line to make it look like
she's spinning to the right so again
it's just showing us that we can all
look at the same thing and not quite see
what everybody else is seeing
so we get into that so
moving on
this is just thinking about we've just
seen a number of examples where we can
have different perspectives on the same
topics
and this conference has been full of so
much knowledge the speakers the talks
the people the tools python have to say
that in there
so much
and we want to make sure that people
outside of this conference are able to
then be able to enjoy or get part of
that knowledge as well
but i started this talk saying that i'd
like to bring more people into the
conversation on data
so let's in order to quote simon sinek
if any of you know him
start with why why do we need to do that
so first of all he's a speaker he's an
author but he talks about with
businesses and leaders that often we
need to start with why we're doing
something so why is it that it's
important to bring
other perspectives and voices into this
conversation on data
well for me the main reason we want to
think of this
is because none of us
whether you're technical not technical
anywhere
none of us ever wants to feel like any
specific algorithm
machine learning model or decision on
data was made for
everyone else except me
so we really want to make sure that
everybody's included whether you are
a developer a coder whether you're a
decision maker or you're actually a user
so it's very important to bring a lot of
these perspectives in
so if we take it now into say machine
learning for a moment and think about
data and data representation
if for example we have um supervised
machine learning and we're doing a
prediction if we are trying to do image
recognition and we've got cats images of
cats and dogs our labeled data set and
okay i know there aren't specifically 50
up here but let's say that we've we've
trained our model on say 50 cats and 50
dogs and then we end up with
we've got a
a
an image i should say down at the bottom
and we're trying to figure out is this a
cat or a dog well of course we humans
know which one it is but the algorithm
can only figure it out based on
the information that's actually been fed
into it
um so when we look at this with an equal
training it's likely to say
most likely it's a dog it's not a cat
okay fair enough we understand that
but what happens then when we're
training our data just thinking about
algorithms now but instead of doing
equal data sets we now do mostly cats
and just say
five seven dogs or so and that's it
and then we try and do a test and we say
let's look at this image what's it gonna
say now
well in this case it's likely to end up
saying okay i don't really know much
about a dog but i know a lot about a cat
and i think maybe it's probably more
likely to be a cat i'm not really sure
or it might be a little bit of a dog
but so this is now just a machine
learning algorithm and an example but i
think the same holds true when we come
to conversations and conversing with
people outside of our specialisms that
the having the other points of view
really make a difference and we need to
know about them
also because
when it comes to data and conversations
that this impacts more than just
businesses and
and data it impacts lives so we want to
have other perspectives in there and
that can often mean than talking to
people outside of our specialism
so it's important to be able to do that
um
and if we're only talking to people that
are specifically in our area or in our
field we end up in these echo chambers
right and we know that that's gone wrong
i think as an american and looking at
some of the past elections perhaps um it
has gone wrong at times or sorry maybe i
shouldn't say gone wrong but it has
gone um
it has it has influenced it has
influenced i'll just say that but so we
want to make sure that we are moving
beyond just the clusters of the people
that we are speaking to
so thinking about this and the clusters
that we we're speaking to
i think it's important because we can
think back to the optical illusions that
we saw and we can see that a number of
us can have different opinions based on
the same thing that we're actually
looking at
and so with that in mind we want to be
able to talk to other people outside of
our specific fields
so another analogy for us
20 years ago i lived in france and uh
just south of paris in fontainebleau
and in fontainebleau there was this
amazing forest that you would walk
through
and to get onto it or to get into it you
would start walking through one of the
paths and of the paths that are actually
there you could see really far ahead of
you and you could see far behind you but
it was impenetrable to the left and the
right you couldn't see what else was out
there
but you might continue on your path and
then find out that the light marks might
start changing at some point and then as
you approached it you'd realize once you
were there you were coming up to an
intersection and only once you were at
that intersection could you see really
far down another path one way or another
and it's once you were at that point you
were able to see
what was happening in that direction of
the forest or another and i think of
that so with these intersections going
through the forest again it's a bit like
conversations and trying to find the
intersection point with others where we
have something in common and we can
converse about other topics
outside of our own specialisms and the
importance of that
so
here's a woman as well dervla murphy and
she was an irish writer and she um
unfortunately passed away last month but
at the um wonderful age of 90 so she um
she had a great life and
she was um quite adventurous
and i like thinking of her because of
thinking about connections and finding
out what's in between
so when she was 10 she was given a
bicycle and an atlas
so a map of you know the world and a
collection of maps and she decided a few
days after that that she wanted to
um
ride her bicycle
from where she was in ireland to india
this was her decision she wanted to do
it 20 plus years later about 20 years
later so i think it was 1963
she did it solo woman on her bicycle she
rode from ireland india i think this is
amazing
she wanted to find out what was in
between what she knew in ireland and
what she didn't know what was in india
so she decided to ride her bike and it's
a great way to find out about what's in
between
so we can think about you know there's a
lot in between ireland and india many
different cultures people
and i'm impressed with all of what she
was trying to figure out
um
the thing is
but what we sometimes find out is that
when we're trying to understand about
these connections and what we know and
what we don't know
p and the connections people won't
easily tell you what they don't know
and i think it's a very human thing and
they often won't tell you um often it's
because we think we should know
and i guess sometimes maybe there's a
little bit of shame involved but we are
humans and so when we're outside our own
specialist area we think about
well i know this maybe should i know
that
and trying to we want to share knowledge
but actually it can be a little bit
difficult
but we do all have i'm a firm believer
in that we all have a strength and
expertise somewhere
but in having that expertise somewhere
sometimes we can get to the point
where we become certain of the outcome
and when we are certain of the outcome
sometimes things don't quite end up the
way we expect
so
i'm going to uh show you a short video
it's less than a minute here
but so again i grew up on the east coast
in the u.s
and um in the winters lots of snow
there people would put out bird feeders
and there would end up being kind of it
was almost like a sport basically my dad
used to kind of almost treated this as a
sport
he'd put out a bird feeder
and of course the squirrels would come
and try and get to the bird feeder so
there are all sorts of kind of deterrent
devices and he had like cones out there
trying to make sure that even when the
squirrel was coming around it couldn't
actually get there um
but
you so back to the idea of you think you
know the outcome
just gonna kind of show us what's
happening here this is quite a familiar
scene for me this is not for me this is
a video i found online
but again thinking about what's
happening i hope sound might work here
no sound is not going to work here
let's do that okay let's do this and
hopefully
um
poor little squirrel's having a tough
time
pulls a little slippery
yep now you're on
still metal
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so okay um
so that that's our video but basically
it's just showing us that this was a bit
of a sport growing up just watching the
squirrel and the bird feeder everything
but it's uh we think we know what's
going to happen basically we kind of
think he's either going to get down
there he's going to get the bird cedar
he's going to end up falling off or
whatever but we did not expect that to
happen so it was just reminding us that
sometimes we don't quite know what's
going to happen okay i'm going to try
and forward the slide without starting
the video again but let's see if that
hang on a second
there
there we go so sometimes we can get
stuck and think we can we know the
outcome but it's not quite um where it's
going so
final almost analogy or points here but
this is this is an article i found in uh
nature physics which actually i found
really interesting and and liked it
because i think it kind of uh breaks the
stories down but so this is talking
about again thinking about all of the
knowledge that we've gained over the
last few days
and how we can go out and communicate
that to our colleagues that are maybe
non-specialists in this area
and how to um
speak to others so i'm going to point um
bring our attention to this picture at
the bottom here
and actually i'm going to kind of bring
this up does anyone know what this is
picture of this
it's hard to maybe tell what it is but
it's me it's it's an animal and there's
a tail and their legs and their horns at
the at the right side so it's actually a
bull and it's from picasso
and so this is kind of um a way of
thinking how we can break it down but so
it's hard to tell but once you someone
says okay here's a bull and this is what
we're looking at
that there are other ways that from
there once you get to the essentials you
can start adding more detail onto it and
you can think about okay you can add
more of the drawing you can add more
detail and then you can even add the
outer coat to kind of explain what else
is there
so sometimes we need to go all the way
down to what we all agree we know
and then add more detail from there in
order to share the message
so communicating results this is from
from the article communicating results
across different disciplines may require
a lot of thought but it's worth the
effort
not only may it inspire others you may
discover new ideas and questions in the
process of breaking down a problem to
its bare essentials
good science communication lies in the
compromise between precision in every
detail and easy to grasp ideas
so for example boss taurus lineas
i didn't know what that was i had to
google it
turns out that's the scientific name for
a bull
so sometimes we think about we might see
something and if it's outside our area
of knowledge we don't know what's
being discussed
maybe even add a picture on there
sometimes that can help too
but so thinking about a lot of these
concepts and trying to break it down so
we want to end up trying to remember the
bull and bring your messages back to the
essentials
so let's go out and bring more of us
into the conversation on data and with
that i will say thank you very much